it seems
that you think that blm and bad science
are eating the world
in the real world though i don't see it
happening what am i missing
you can't pay the rent with your waste
race or sex isn't reality unmovable
so that's i think that's a coherent set
of things although the
individual thoughts there um seem to be
going all over the place a little bit
but
i mean i think the basic question is in
in my world the person asking the
question
i'm not seeing uh the effects of black
lives matter
or of bad science on on
my on my lifestyle and my career on
anything
um i would say that you're lucky
and that many many people are and that
whether or not you can see it yet
doesn't mean that it's not having the
effects that those of us who are seeing
it
um say it does i feel like you're
objecting no i i agree
i think i'm having a little trouble
imagining how
you could miss the hazard of it given
what it is
demanding um miss the hazard you said
right i mean for one thing i mean if it
was if it was a totally fringe thing
right right and um it really was a
couple of yahoos
and the mainstream media was actually
blowing it out of proportion instead of
completely minimizing it right
um then yeah you could you they could be
doing exactly the same thing and if it
was five people
you know in each in a handful of cities
then
why are we talking about something sure
but you know we could and
many did do the same thing with uh
you know the de-platforming that was
going on on college campuses and the
point was
how serious actually is this the answer
is it's really goddamn serious and you
can now see that because it's driving
murder rates up inside of major cities
that are
run by uh democratic administrations
right so you know if death is bad
and murder tends to kill people then
it would seem that this is a serious
issue because lots of people are no
longer walking the earth who presumably
would have been uh but for this um
this tantrum yeah but you know the last
question
excuse me isn't reality unmovable um
yes certainly the one of the central
tenets at the core of what we're talking
about is that there is an objective
reality out there whether or not
uh we will ever actually get to it but
the scientific method allows us to
approach it as an asymptote and we never
know
we only occasionally will know under
certain circumstances how close we
actually are
to the objective reality that's out
there that said
there was a lot about the human
experience that is not directly
reflective of the objective reality and
so
given that the for instance schools of
education at least the united states are
pretty well captured
by this kind of thinking uh and the
graduates of those schools will be going
out
and becoming k-12 teachers for instance
primary and secondary school teachers
what will it do to a whole generation or
whole generations
of children's minds who grow up thinking
patently untrue things and with no
skills in their back pockets with which
to determine whether or not what they're
saying or
thinking is actually reflective of
reality
um and so you know from there it's a hop
skip and a jump to
we have engineering schools that are
encouraging
yeah i don't know if it's there's
actually queering of engineering but um
you know there's a lot of bad rhyme yeah
um
but uh god many episodes ago we talked
about
some phd thesis in a in an engineering
school um
being being defended that was clearly
intersectional and you know
at the point that bridges start falling
down obviously you have
uh a direct conflict between
intersectionality
and and reality you know where civil
engineering just can't accommodate this
but there's a whole lot of space between
um you know totally social constructed
stuff over here
and you know does the bridge stand or
not and
the vast majority of where most of us
spend our time is in some place
hopefully a little bit closer to
um does the bridge stand or not but
there's still enough
interpretation by people of what it
means
that whether or not their beliefs
reflect reality or not
actually really does matter i also
flatly disagree that you can't pay the
rent
with your race or sex um this is at this
point this is
clearly one of the uh the most
actionable items on the demand list is
you know they're going to create
positions where ostensibly the purpose
of the decision the
position is to figure out what to do
about diversity equity and inclusion
problems but of course the position can
only be inhabited by somebody who meets
the criteria
and so this is a way of skirting the
normal process by declaring
something necessary which then installs
particular demographic requirements
associated with it
right and you know we're now seeing this
in you know with boardroom requirements
and all sorts of things so
and whole divisions of of colleges you
know
i'm a i don't know about a majority a
large number and a growing number of
colleges and universities
at least in the u.s have not just
sort of departments dedicated to equity
and inclusion
but whole divisions of the college and
indeed this is this is not the time
place i'd have to go back and look at
the various numbers but
um one of the things that happened at
evergreen was exactly
the um downgrading of academics
as one of originally four divisions of
the college yes academics was only one
of four
um but the other the other three were
reasonable there was basically
student affairs which is everything to
do with um you know
housing and food and clubs and health
care and you know all of this and there
was
um basically finance and administration
you know the
all the all the running of the college
that included things like the physical
plant
and then there was um i don't remember
the names of them but effectively
um outreach pr right um which you know
looked
to alums and looked to the public and
looked outside for you know how it is
that you get money that's not coming
from the state
so academics of course is what the core
of a college or university is
or should be should be um but even in
its original formulation at evergreen
which is just the system we know best it
was only one of four
um most universities which are just
colleges that have phd granting
authority
they're bigger there are presumably more
divisions than that
but one of the things that the not so
hapless
but um you know perhaps intent on
destroying the college president at
evergreen did
was demoted academics and created
two new divisions of the college
including one and again i don't know
exactly what it's i don't remember
exactly what it's called because i don't
have my notes up here right now but a
diversity equity inclusion
um vice president and all of the staff
accompanying that so whereas before
there had been four vps
academic student affairs finance and
admin or whatever in
public relations or whatever it was
called now there was additionally
um a vp at the same level for equity and
inclusion which
is extremely highly paid with you know
in the hierarchy of
positions somebody who did not have lots
of experience as somebody who jumped a
bunch of levels and was
suddenly being paid you know 100 000
plus a year more than that but it was it
was a lot of money for evergreen in
particular
um and the and and they needed to staff
her entire
right right every and and you don't you
don't staff those positions
either without while being blind to
things like race and sex and that's
that's an abomination yeah and so in
that case that was bridges falling down
on the job
yeah that was that was my line dude oh
did you say that something well actually
not bridges fallen
falling down the job i referred to
faculty trolls hiding under bridges yes
yes go yes so sorry it's a redux but
uh but it's different yeah it's
different um so
in any case uh yeah the final thing
um that i would say there is just think
back to what we were talking about in
the first hour
with respect to the university of
chicago and what it's doing to english
that's a career path that is now being
uh explicitly narrowed to people who
only espouse
um one interest and presumably one
perspective on it
um so anyway yes you can very definitely
pay the rent with this stuff and that's
a hazard to everything else that should
be
[Music]
rewarded